السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا الله
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين
اما بعد معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان
اصدق الكلام كلام الله عز وجل وخير الهدي
هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وان شر
الامور محدثاتها وان كل محدثه بدعه وان كل
بدعه
ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في النار اسال الله
العظيم رب العرش العظيم بمنه وكرمه وعفوه
ان يجيرني واياكم منها انه ولي ذلك
والقادر عليه اما بعد فيقول الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما
رجالا كثيرا ونساء واتقوا الله الذي
تساءلون به والارحام ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا تموتن الا
وانتم مسلمون
ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما ا
بعد شاء الله
ان شاء الله كلما اتسع العالم وتطورت
الاحوال والوسائل والمعاملات زادت الرغبات
والحاجات وبالتالي زادت الشهوات والشبهات
وكثره الفتن وهذا معلوم ففتن اليوم على
كثرتها تشابه واشتبهت على الناس فالناس
اليوم منهم من هو مفتون بمال ومنهم من هو
مفتون بولد ومنهم من هو مفتون بوظيفه
ومنهم من هو مفتون في مسكن ومنهم من هو
مفتون في ماكل ومنهم من هو مفتون في مشرب
وتعددت وتعددت الفتن على اختلاف انواعها
والفتن اليوم للتامل يجدها من كل صوت بل
اضف الى هذا كله ما استجد من التكنولوجيا
واساليب الرفاهيه وهذا وهذا هو حال المؤمن
لازال ولا يكون لا كان ولا
يزال دينه وحياته
محفوفه بالفتن والشبهات لقوله سبحانه
وتعالى احسب الناس ان يتركوا ان يقولوا
امنا وهم لا يفتنون ولقد فتنا الذين من
قبلهم فليعلمن الله الذين صدقوا وليعلمن
الكذبين and
advan from tool ways me technic
advances ched and advances so we feel
desires of people andes
[Silence]
‏not incre
asr
from
and the risk from of those
temptations people not have the
knowledge
حلال
حرام فتنه شبه والشبه هي التي لا يستطيع
المر ان يميز ان كانت حلالا او حراما مما
استجد من الامور
[Silence]
‏end
end
and come
[Silence]
‏because
ex currency back days years back
would see how the exp
[Silence]
قران الله سبحانه وتالى
say
think say believe
they
trials
being احسب الناس ان يقولوا امنا ان
يتركوا ان يقولوا امنا وهم لا يفتنون
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى اخي المسلم اليوم المحروم من حرم
الادراك واليقظه والفطن الموفق من استبرا
لدينه وعرضه كما دلت السنه الشريفه
دافع الخطبه اليوم لعله معلوم في كل حلقه
نتدارس فيها او نجتمع فيها بعض الاخوه
يسال عن حرمه امتلاك المنازل عن طريق
البنك واخر يسال عن حرمه المعاملات
البنكيه والثالث عن المداولات الرقميه
والرابع يسال عن طعام بعض المطاعم فهذه
التساؤلات ان دلت انما تدل على حرص
المسلمين في نا بالشبهات والتور في الامور
كلها ونحن اليوم ليس بصدد تفصيل
وتبيين هذه الامور والمسائل المذكوره من
حر تبيين حرمتها من عدمه انما هو الهدف هو
لفت انتباهك او انتباهك اخي المسلم كيف
اصبحت الفتن تحيط بالمسلمين من كل صوت
لذلك كان هنالك امور يحتمها الشر عليك
لتجنب الوقوع في هذ
[Silence]
المران some things
حال
حرام
them
house حال
حرام can eat not can
‏myle
[Silence]
ولما كانت هذه الفتن تمر وتتجدد في كل
زمان وتخرج باساليب مختلفه حذرنا منها
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ف ففي الحديث
عنه صلى الله عليه وسلم قال بادروا
بالاعمال الصالحه فتنا كقطع الليل المظلم
يصبح الرجل يصبح الرجل مؤمنا ويمسي كافرا
ويمسي مؤمنا يصبح كافرا يبيع يبيع دينه
بعرض من الدنيا فقوله صلى الله عليه وسلم
بادروا اي اي استعجلوا وسارعوا قبل ان
يتعذر
عليكم يتعذر
عليكم او تشغلكم هذه الفتن التي كقطع
الليل المظلم يلتبس فيها الحق
بالباطل وتعريف بعض العلماء ليصبح يصبح
المرء في المسلم في يصبح المرء الرجل
مسلما ويمسي كافرا ويمسي مسلما ويصبح
كافرا يقولون انه يصبح محرما لدم اخيه
وماله وعرضه ويمسي مستحلا لدمه وماله
وعرضه فتن
وابتلاءات
ومحن والفتن نوعين كما قسمها العلماء هي
شبهات وعلاجها العلم
الشرعي والالتزام الديني والقسم الثاني هي
فتن شهوات وعلاجها الايمان
والصب صلى الله عليه
وسلم حديث
ابو هريره رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم
dark
dark حى
[Silence]
‏over
‏ty
des
things
and desire cure
for انصب
حلال
حرام
call
شبهات شهوات
وشبهات التورع والتفقه في الدين من اعظم
الم المجيات في زمان الفتن والاشتباه عن
النعمان بن البشير رضي الله عنهما قال
سمعت رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
ان الحلال بين والحرام بين وبينهما امور
مشتبهات لا
يعل لا يعلمهن كثير من
الناس فمن اتقى الشبهات فقد استبرا لدينه
وعرضه ومن وقع في الشبهات وقع في الحرام
الى اخر
الحديث اناند
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ح حم
صل الله عليه
وسلم them this is only way
protect and حال حال
حرام حرام
بارك الله لي ولكم في القران العظيم
ونفعني واياكم بهدي سيد المرسلين اقول ما
تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم فاستغفروه
انه الغفور
[Silence]
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على المبعوث رحمه
للعالمين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اللهم وارضى
عنا وعنهم اجمعين ولعل من اكثر واشد الفتن
فتكا بدين المرء هي التي يفعلها المرء
ويصر عليها بدرا مع درايه اي مفتون ويعلم
انه مفتون ولا يسال الله الهدايه والثبات
فهذه التي تحبط الدنيا والدين ولان النجاه
من الفتن لا يكون الا بالدعاء لا يكون لا
تكون النجاه من الفتن الا بالدعاء
بالحمايه من شرور الفتن فهو سبب من اسباب
النجاه ففي مسند احمد قوله صلى الله عليه
وسلم واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه ان تقبضني
اليك غير مفتون وفي دعاء عمر رضي الله عنه
نعوذ بالله من ش من شر الفتن وقال انس رضي
الله عنه عائذا بالله من شر الفتن وينجيك
عند الله من الفتن ان تنكر الفتنه ولا
ترضى بهاها لا ترضى بالفتنه ولا تق تقرها
ولا تعين عليها قال صلى الله عليه وسلم
واي قلب انكرها نكتت فيه نكته نكته بيضاء
حتى يصير القلب ابيض مثل الصفاء لا تضره
فتنه فتنه مادام السماوات
والارض ومن اهم المنجيات ان يفقه المرء
دينه وان يميز حدود الشرع دون التباس فقد
نقل حديثا عن حذيفه رضي الله عنه يقول لا
تضرك الفتنه ما عرفت دينك لا تضرك الفتنه
ما عرفت دينك انما الفتنه ذا اشتبه عليك
الحق والباطل
[Silence]
‏saved
‏and حثر and
to ش the of ش
look things
doled العاء and proper
anding those among
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏itone and
no as as heav earth
exine all
[Silence]
شاء
الله اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في
الاولين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في
الاخرين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في وقت
كل وقت
وحين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محد محمد
حتى ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم ارحم ضعفنا اللهم ارحم
ضعفنا واجمع شملنا واجبر كسرنا ويسر امرنا
وفرج همنا واشرح صدورنا ووسع ارزاقنا
واقضي عنا ديننا اللهم تقبل توبتنا واغسل
حوبتنا واجب دعوتنا وثبت حجتنا واهد
قلوبنا وسدد السنتنا يا رب العالمين اللهم
اللهم سدد السنتنا واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا يا
بفضلك يا رب العالمين اللهم اشف مرضانا
ومرضى المسلمين وارحم موتانا وموتى
المسلمين وعاف مبتلانا واجعل لنا بكل دعوه
اجابه وبلغنا رضاك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
اعز الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واصلح احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان
اللهم احفظنا واحفظهم بما تحفظ به اوليائك
اللهم اسقنا الغيث ولا تجعلنا من القانطين
اللهم اجعل هذا المجتمع سخاء رخاء وسائر
بلاد المسلمين اللهم تجاوز عنا السيئات
وتحمل عنا التبعات اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا
خير الجزاء اللهم اجز والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء
اللهم بارك لهم في اعمارهم واعمالهم واختم
لنا ولهم
بخاتمه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد واله
وصحبه وسلم واخر دعوانا عن الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووا واستقيم واعتدلوا للصلاه اثابكم
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين يسالك
الناس عن
الساعه قل
انما علمها عند
الله قل
انما علمها عند الله وما يدريك لعل الساعه
تكون
قريبا ان الله لعن
الكافرين واعد لهم
سعيرا خالدين
فيها ابدا لا يجدون وليا
ولا
نصيرا يوم تقلب وجوههم في
النار يقولون يا
ليتنا اطعنا الله واطعنا
الرسولا وقالوا
ربنا
انا اطعنا سادتنا وكبراء
فاضلونا
السبيلا
ربنا اتهم ضعفين من
العذاب ربنا اتهم ضعفين من العذاب
والعنهم
لعنا كبيرا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا زلزلت الارض
زلزالها واخرجت الارض
اثقالها وقال
الانسان ما لها
يومئذ تحدث
اخبارها
بان ربك اوحى
لها
يومئذ يصدر الناس اشتات ليروا
اعمالهم فمن يعمل مثقال ذره
خيرا
يره ومن يعمل مثقال
ذره
شرا
يره الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله استغفر الله
السلام علرح الله
وكه السلام علكم
[Silence]
‏syn
was and
inve
ch was
‏prev
ier some
[Silence]
‏come list because i tell are for
those
much
they pleas take
‏also announcement the winners compe
630m there conflict of time please join
ear for
that last but not least if you want your
to be diver and not be put through the
state syst so it goes to oppressing and
besieging brother and sisters abro
arizona allows you to divert your state
taxes so they can be
‏easy
[Silence]
‏all
السلام